[Musique]
cet architecte est venu acheter du cbd
l'abréviation de cannabis violent une
molécule non psychotropes issus du
cannabis ça c'est agréable et relaxant
et donc en fait finalement saxe est bien
aussi c'est qu'on est obligé de fumée on
peut le mettre dans du thé il y avait
ceux ci de l'huile au culte mais sous la
langue
le cbd et ses propriétés relaxantes
compte de plus en plus d'adeptes
j'adore la plante est dénuée de tout
c'est psychoactifs donc ça fait que
c'est légal sa vente n'était jusque là
pas autorisée en france le 19 novembre
dernier la cour de justice de l'union
européenne a jugé cette interdiction
illégale depuis les boutiques de cbd
floris tu ferais quoi s'il te restait
trois jours à vivre
je fumerai comme une vache je picole ray
comme un trou et je ferai beaucoup
l'amour ha
[Rires]
[Musique]
ma maison ma tour eiffel vous rappeler
d'autres maladies qui m'appelle la tour
eiffel ou jsk ou bouquets ou passé non
mais sans déconner je te rappelle que tu
passes à la télé là le prétentieux son
couvre très bien desbiens janvier
dernier en fait dans le pays les couples
qui divorcent ont le droit de demander
une indemnisation s'il considère avoir
assumer davantage de responsabilités à
la maison une information reçue cinq sur
cinq par madame wang femme au foyer qui
a déclaré devant un tribunal de pékin
s'être occupé de son fils et du ménage
durant son mariage quand son mari se
prélassaient tranquille après le travail
c'est possible d'être mort et vivant en
même temps ah oui ça c'est possible mais
il y en a beaucoup des gens qui sont
vivants mais morts en même temps
résultat la justice a demandé au père de
famille 6400 euros de compensation ce
serait a priori une première dans le
pays et cette histoire a été très
commentée par les médias les réseaux
sociaux sur place dans un contexte où
l'indépendance financière des femmes se
renforce et madame wang n'a pas dit son
dernier mot puisqu'elle a fait appel de
la décision elle demande plus de 20000
euros
[Musique]
les coréens du sud
oui quand ils inventer une tendance la
tendance des vidéos gong bangalore
attention à ne pas confondre avec les
vidéos de gang bang qui sont autrement
plus dynamique les vidéos de gang bang
donnerais tu as regardé sur internet
elisabeth ce soir gang bang vous verrez
la barre sorte d'orgie mais là on est
loin de lorgies on peut même plutôt
parler de plaisir solitaire puisque on
les découvre des étudiants esseulé qui
se filment en train de réviser me sentir
ça en toi comment tu te sens ça fait du
bien
il se filme en silence leur pendant
plusieurs heures plans fixes soit dans
leur chambre ou alors dans une
bibliothèque est là et bien les autres
étudiants en observant ces étudiants en
silence et bien trouverait dans cette
vidéo un petit peu de réconfort de
compagnie et de motivation dans un
étonnant effet miroir
j'appelle tous les étudiants à se
révolter contre un confinement globale
si jamais il y en a un nouveau oui à se
révolter jeunesse à tours 1 re in the
belly sens civique puissante car le mot
même de confinement je nous donne
aujourd'hui la faisait appel à la
désobéissance je suis obligé de rouler
c'est l'arrachage agressé la chaux dans
le monde du travail c'est chaud pour les
augmentations
d'ailleurs d'après un rapport de
l'institution défenseur des droits les
salariés jugés beaux sont payés 12 % de
plus tandis que les personnes au
physique disgracieux en paire de 10 à
15%
c'est pour ça que tel que vous me voyez
je force un peu sur l'ombre à paupières
sur cette photo
stella n'est encore qu'un petit garçon
mais pense déjà à changer d'identité et
sadio fin du feeling mad ce n'est que
pendant le premier confinement qu'elle
ose enfin exprimer sa souffrance son mal
être
stella ne veut plus être un garçon alors
filé dans les coulisses ce soir là quand
tu apprends que tu as le droit de
t'appeler stella c'est le plus beau
cadeau de noël que tu pouvais envisager
oui pourquoi c'était si important de
t'appeler stella est ce que depuis que
je suis un garçon je me sens mal dans ce
corps et fallait absolument que je
redevienne que je devienne qui j'étais
vraiment c'était la pause déjà beaucoup
de questions à sa maman elle s'interroge
sur son avenir et la possibilité de se
faire opérer plus tard
est-ce que c'est super que que ton petit
et zhu pets être un peu qu'il fait
exactement tu m'avais demandé ça oui
c'est ce que tu espères saft est là et
puis a les cheveux aux etats unis le
simple fait d'être blonde peut augmenter
le salaire de 7 % par rapport aux brunes
une vraie faute de goût si vous voulez
mon avis alors explique moi mon arrière
grand père c'est carla gars y est
pardon regard hagard 6 à malaga inc
l'allemand est une très très très belle
langue par exemple defunzu l'hedim
balles deux jolies voix sinon il fait
valoir
dix balles de ces sacem vient d'être
adressé ce message là non mais c'est
important si je traduis ça veut dire les
oraisons chante dans la forêt ballerine
qui nous offre son interprétation du lac
des cygnes de tchaïkovski sur labège les
deux batailles reina ya
dans le golfe de finlande elle espère
ainsi sauver une plage d'un projet de
construction portuaire
la ballerine russe est également à
l'origine d'une pétition en ligne à
l'attention de vladimir poutine lui
demandant l'annulation du projet mais en
tout cas ce que je te défonce et que le
conseil scientifique je vous dis qu on
est gouvernés par la peur et à cause de
gens comme vous que si c'est bon tu ne
visait rien et qu'effectivement venez
pérorer sur des plateaux télé
est ce que concrètement vous ne lisez
vous ne comprenez rien mais alors je
suis un peu d'accord avec vous que vous
venez pérorer sur merci à ce monsieur
roch l'or lui je sais qu'il a de
l'humour parce que quand je fais des
petites chansons parfois sur les ca ne
fait pas toujours mais lui il a été très
solide dans sa négociation
il était solide comme un roc c'est
qu'ils connaissent quelqu'un que je
déteste par exemple ce même rick car on
m'a donné quand même l' envie de manger
moins de viande moins jeunes aux données
pour vous dire que là ils essaient
bricard eaux tranquilles et complexe
même chez des gens qu'on méprise on peut
avoir des choses intéressantes
la coqueluche du moment s'appelle barack
c'est le petit nom donné par un refuge
australien à ce mouton sauvage découvert
dans une forêt avec 35 kg de laine sur
le dos ces six de moins que le record du
monde mais cela reste très
impressionnant
au point que 20 millions d'internautes
ont regardé la remise en beauté de
barack devenue méconnaissable après sa
tante